le 26 avril 2001 loana petrucciani 24
ans à peine fait ses premiers pas à la
télévision devant des millions de
français
immédiatement elle tape dans l'oeil des
téléspectateurs qui n'ont d'yeux que
pour la sulfureuse blonde aux yeux bleus
à la plastique idéal et au tempérament
affirmé dès les premiers jours de
l'aventuré loana crève l'écran et
devient la star du programme love story
à l'époque un événement national c'est
après sa victoire aux côtés de
christophe à sa sortie du loft que loana
se rend compte de son incroyable
popularité célébrité soudaine et
délicate à gérer pour la jeune femme
très vite elle transforme cette
fascination collective en un véritable
business musique clips stylisme
collaboration artistique avec jean paul
gaultier
rien ne résiste à la tornade loana elle
lancera successivement une marque de
vêtements et un parfum qui s'arrache son
autobiographie elle m'appelait miette
est devenu un véritable best seller en
s'écoulant à plus de cent dix mille
exemplaires
bref lohan a ouvert le siècle en
devenant l'icône de toute une génération
et c'est notre témoin du jour je sais
que vous l'attendez loana merci d'être
là
merci beaucoup loana merci loana d'être
là alors on a plein de choses à te dire
oui déjà
j'aimerais qu'on voit avec toi tes
premiers pas dans le loft en 2001
jouissent à ce que j'aimerais qu'on leur
voix avant qu'on discute tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis ya certes eu va
quérir une popularité exceptionnelle
j'aimerais qu'on regarde tout ton
portrait dans le loft
regardez loana en 2001 regarde pour
portrait malouda loana a 23 ans et
depuis cinq ans elle est gogo dancer je
vais une certaine image rambos excellent
travail on va donner donc payet cette
année d une chance très étrange
en fait je très introverti chansons
depuis la vocation de loana ce n'était
pas de danser sur des podiums mais ses
17 ans lorsque sa mère est hospitalisée
elle se retrouve seule pour faire face
au quotidien
je voulais vraiment faire des études
poussées est en fait la vie a fait que
ma mère est partie de chez moi j'avais
une amie qui était dans le style art
janvier
viens je t'apprendrai commencé à jeter
prêtres et des tenues au départ j'ai
commencé comme ça voilà un couac couture
vois ça c'est fou car oui dit att et et
c'est ça te fait quelque chose
ouais ça me savais me c'est un beau
souvenir où c'est tuer un trait c'est un
très beau souvenir tu regrettes un bon
de l'avoir fait ou sur ladite sous
jamais jeunes à changer ma vie ça
changer ta vie alors j'ai changé ma vie
ouais loana je devrais dire déjà merci
d'être là en entrant dans le neuf
c'était quoi ton objectif à la hausse
était injuste de faire une à une
aventure avec des amis c'est ça donc
après ça devient la folie tenaris par
tes la plus grande star de téléréalité
tcc l'aplomb des la première c'est la
première évidemment il ya après voilà
exactement les mêmes pas parce
qu'effectivement rappelez-vous le
déferlement elle remonte l'avenue de la
grande-armée phénomène qui va au delà de
regarder où là c'est à dire regarde
évidemment cic regarde vous pouvez le
constater c'est normal c'est la sortie
de l'auteur avec les vainqueurs ça c'est
énorme
ça bouge de boucau mais rassurez vous
les
mais très rapidement on a peut-être un
tout petit mot lorraine à ta première ta
première réaction loana loi n'a alors on
va faire monter la tension parce que on
peut s'attendre évidemment et une
déferlante à bien vendre un mec
montauban les reconnais je vous assure
là j'ai l'impression réellement de me
retrouver au bon vieux temps en 81 18
finales de la coupe du monde france
brésil
des fois mais la loana très vite tes la
coqueluche des français
les français adorent été sollicités de
partout en 2009 sortira une
autobiographie miettes qui se vendra
plus de cent mille exemplaires la
musique voilà tu sors en 2001 le single
comme je t'aime qui se hissera la 18
plaide 6 8e place du classement singles
en france
jean paul gaultier s'intéresse à toi il
te fait défiler pour ses nouvelles
collections oui c'est des souvenirs
incroyables pour toi tu deviens même
styliste et imagine ta propre ligne de
vêtements oui ta place dans la presse il
ya eu pénurie des miniers deux magazines
avec en couverture
loana et luan a eu la gloire c'est la
chute libre
ça a été la fibre mais au fil des années
ta sortie du loft l'euphorie retombe et
tu te retrouves de moins en moins
sollicités c'est pas que j'ai été de
moins en moins sollicités c'est que
c'est moi qui ai fait la bêtise d'être
mal entouré est de moi répondre aux
sollicitudes c'est ça alors un moment tu
as vraiment plongé dans la drogue
oui c'est ce que tu dis bien suffit pas
c'est comment ça s'est passé parce que
avant de rentrer dans le loft
wilko nerfs se connaître ce succès ne
souffre que tu connaissais la drogue est
ce que tu étais dans donc dans ses
délires ou pas du tout non je n'étais
pas du tout mais j'avais 23 ans c'est
pas le loft comme on dit qui m'a fait
plonger dedans ça et elle est mauvaise
rencontre j'avais 30 ans je suis tombé
dedans
donc voilà et donc derrière
qu'est ce qui se passe il paraît que tu
disais tu dis à un moment que tu prenais
de la drogue au petit déjeuner oui c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui est qui et
alcoolique et qui boit son verre
d'alcool matin au réveil et ben moi je
prenais de la drogue
matin au réveil tu prenais quoi la
cauquenne c'est à dire donc le matin au
réveil tu te réveiller et que je prenais
j'apprenais je prenais un tramway
jusqu'au soir donc en fait comment toute
la journée et ont foulé journée way et
entendre dedans comme on tombe dans la
colle donc les gens ne font que boire et
je suis tombé dans la drogue comme on
tombe dans le port d'une aide et la
drogue comme ça pour oublier pour
oublier ça ne devient pas didier quoi
pour oublier les gens qui étaient autour
de moi avec lui ne faisait du mal c'est
qui ces gens qui étaient autour de toi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après le loft
ça a été longtemps après le loft parce
que pendant dix ans j'ai j'ai été comme
ça donc c était que dix ans plus tard
après loft que tu t'en mets dans ses
addictions la fusion mais dans l'alcool
selon mehr la drogue
je voulais oublier je voulais oublier ma
vie tous les oublis et a dit je vais
oublier ma vie qui me convenait pas oui
tu as gagné beaucoup d'argent
j'ai gagné beaucoup d'argent et
détestions ten de milliers d'euros oui
ça se chiffre à combien à peu près
presque un million un million d'euros
pas plus non un million de roubles
forcément tu as tu as tout cramé j'ai
pas tout cramer justement j'ai rien
n'est pensé on a tout cramé à ma place
de toukra matin passent mais la drogue
c'est comment tu quittes kit fourni
c'est cette drogue mon petit copain
était de 10 heures à l'époque à d'accord
ça aide pas à être pas du saut c'est ça
fait partie des exclus des
fréquentations qui tombe fait plonger
exactement bien sûr ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui me disait de ne pas en
prendre c'est quelqu'un qui me disent il
fut justement d'en prendre pour pas que
tu t'en sors tant fait pour pas que je
m'en sas et j'étais beaucoup plus
manipulable c'est ça ces jours là tu les
as connu à la sortie du loft
non je n'ai pas connu a la certitude que
j'ai connu beaucoup plus tard il est
intéressé par toi pourquoi ils vous
lisant vous l'at-on argent il voulait
parler à mon argent il en voulait à ma
célébrité il en voulait et quand tu dis
que c'est pas toi l'asvel est à 23 ans
je suis tombé dans mes addictions à peu
près vers mes 30 ans donc sept ans après
le loft donc les ai pas rencontrés après
le jeu je les ai rencontrés en arrivant
à paris est
quand tu dis on a dépensé l'argent
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il est pas si
vous sur millions dans les poches de mon
ex et de ma mère de ta mère c'est ce qui
s'est passé que ta mère elle elle donner
les informations à mon ex de mes codes
de carte bleue sous forme de choses donc
puisqu'il est dépensé et pour quoi elle
faisait ça par méchanceté
tu as porté plainte contre le tabac mon
hier oui mais pourquoi ta maman faisait
ça vous êtes vous êtes vous entendiez
bien avant ouais on s'entendait bien
avant mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce qui a fait que je sais pas
elles t'ont veut je serai pas dissous
elle donne était code de carte bleue à
ton ton ex dealer
non il était pas d'hier alors d'accord
c'est frais de covin c'était l'autre la
gta ne l'était pas non d'accord et ta
mère tu essaies discute avec elle voit
un petit peu ouais ce que tu as dit elle
me dit que c'est pas vrai mais mille
cent mille euros
il nous reste dix mille à l'enduro rue
il me reste dix mille euros d'envolées
800 vélos
on m'a volé 800000 euros et et il met
aussi sol natal et il a une décapotable
avec une moto d'accord et moi il me
reste dix mille euros promis devra donc
on se demande pas où est l'argent on
sait ou inspirés mais loana tu te
rendais pas compte de ça parce que ces
huit cent mille euros on les prend pas
en une fois c'était en plein de fois en
sept ans en sept ans et toi tu t'en dis
tu t'es jamais rendu compte de rien
parce que tu es t sous l'emprise de la
drogue
non parce que je suis bipolaire donc en
fait ce qui fait que quand on me donne
pas les médicaments je suis en
dépression donc je me rends pas compte
de ce qui se passe autour de moi je n'ai
pas été dans la drogue pendant sept ans
un oui mais quand tu dis que tu était
bipolaire est ce que tu était bipolaire
est ce que tu avais des dépressions
quand tu étais dans le loft déjà oui oui
déjà
oui oui la bipolarité c'est une maladie
qu'on a depuis toujours d'accord alors
bien sûr que je l'avais elle était moins
importante et elle s'est accentuée de
par le fait que j'ai pris justement ces
addictions la drogue ctc ton sortir
parfois ou bien à chaque fois d'essayer
d'en sortir et urt on gc lâche pas
demande sarthe hier je replongeais et à
un moment j'ai décidé de m'en sortir je
m'en suis sorti comment tu as fait pour
t'en sortir je me suis dit à un moment
qu'il fallait que fallait que ça change
je faisais 49 kg c'était il ya plus de
dix ans de ça c'était c'est pas
maintenant et je faisais 49 kg je
mangeais plus je ne dormais plus
ea et donc il ya un moment donné où on
se dit faut arrêter et et j'ai voulu
arrêter j'avoue vraiment que ça a été le
moment le plus pénible âmes agirait
alors cette descente aux enfers elle
n'en finit plus un moment tu vas penser
au pire
oui et en 2007 tu tombes de mettre fin à
ses jours pour notre de médicaments mais
qu'est ce que tu t'es dit ce jour là tu
t'es dit je m'en sortirais jamais je
veux arrêter je suis exactement ça
tirait jamais j'ai voulu mourir donc on
regarde le soleil pour la dernière fois
on fait un câlin à mon chien pour la
dernière fois et on prend des
médicaments pour en finir avec la vie
j'ai essayé pas qu'une fois j'ai essayé
cette fois c'est cette fois tout je suis
là et fait deux arrêts cardiaques et
3com à bray sur une durée de quatre ans
je m'en suis sorti parce que j'ai une
bonne étoile
c'est pour ça qu'il faudra en parler
maintenant parce que justement j'ai eu
une bonne étoile mais pas tout le monde
peut avoir une bonne étoile alors aux
minutes descente aux enfers il ya une
relation qui tape on sait pas si elle te
idée ou pas ce qu'un acquis disquette
tijd il y en a qui disent qu au
contraire ça t'a pas beaucoup aidé c'est
ton histoire avec fred cauvin ton ex
petit ami non ça m'a enfoncé il m'a il
m'a frappé il m'a descendu
elle ne m'a pas aidé du tout c'est lui
qui m'a jamais fait une tentative de
suicide à cause de lui en 2013 a dit
amoureuse de lui j'étais à moi celui ci
à quoi celui que j'ai
que j'ai fait 120 kg cachée sur son
école était sous son emprise
complètement 13 on appelle ça un pervers
narcissique hier mots comment comment ça
se passait quand tu disais que tu étais
sous son emprise
ça se matérialiser par quoi comment donc
au jour le jour c'est quelqu'un qui vous
descend et qui vous dit que vous êtes
une plus une [ __ ] il moins que rien on
perd en continu et donc avait
complètement perdu confiance en toi
complètement et après ils votent ils que
vous avez de la chance d'être avec
quelqu'un comme lui vous le croyez sur
la fin donc toi tu disais que son lui tu
pouvais pas vivre exactement
voilà et donc tu pouvais pas le quitter
je ne pouvais pas le quitter à cause de
ça et donc même si tu faisais du mal oui
tu pouvais pas le quitter exactement
comme quand il ya des hommes des femmes
battues à la restera juste eu mans il ya
quelques mois tu va envoyer des vidéos
montrant tes bras et les cuisses plaine
de bleu il m'a fait 30 et matam en
quatre heures qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il m'a travaillé pendant quatre heures à
la suite de quoique ce qui s'est passé
parce que c'est incroyable d'entendre ça
en fait sombrer texte c'était parce que
je lui avais mis un coupe-ongles roulier
dans sa trousse à sa trousse de toilette
ou quoi oui mais il m'a dit roudier le
coupon gay il m'a frappée pendant quatre
heures et j'ai des hématomes c'est pas
du maquillage parce que lui lécher de
maquiller elle fait pas du mcc et agen
s'est réellement des hématomes un ballon
on le voit bien oui oui en attendant
4h54 art il m'a frappé d'apporter plein
oui je te sont très ému quand tu vois ça
c'est des souvenirs qu'ils doivent eux
c'était l'année dernière sera plus de
trente hématome ce que vous voyez c'est
une partie mon corps était recouvert
pour arriver à ça là pendant quatre
heures il m'a frappé en traitant de
kaunas c'était deux jours avant mon
anniversaire
tu la quittes est aujourd'hui la plus
aucune relation avec lui non parce que
je sais que comme tu nous expliquer
c'est que parfois il faisait du mal mais
tu retournes avec lui parce que sa toile
et cette fois-ci nantes puis depuis
cette fois là non alors law and haas
si je résume tu sors du loft
tout marche pour toi oui ensuite c'est
une descente aux enfers tu fais des
mauvaises rencontres
oui aujourd'hui ta famille ta maman tu
t'es rendu compte qu'elle l'avait trahi
oui ton amoureux c'est un pervers
narcissique qui te frapper ouais donc à
l'automne dernier et est hospitalisé
plus placé en hôpital psychiatrique où
c'est c'est toi que qu'est ce qui s'est
passé comment comment qui tient cette
demande tant dans la folie c'est à dire
comment tu te sens tu es tu tombé dans
la folie ou complètement département non
je sentais que le temps mais dans la
folie parce que quand vous avez la
famille que vous travaillez votre petit
ami qui vous frappe ou au bout d'un
moment c'était quoi la folie têtu
comment tu te sens tu es qu'est ce qui
se passait je me sentais partir je me
sentais ne plus avoir de réflexion
logique en fait pour moi là je de le
monde il était plus il était plus normal
enfin je sais pas comment digérer et ça
fait du bien là le séjour en hôpital
oui beaucoup tassotti tu as eu des
personnes qui tout est dit oui sans toi
g été que quinze jours et pendant ces
quinze jours là on m'a énormément aidé
on m'a repris on m'a donné confiance en
moi et j'étais en mois d'octobre et donc
depuis 20 je vais beaucoup mieux alors
je veux revenir aussi sur un autre point
avec toi oui que la mère d'une petite
fille née trois ans dans le loft en 98
mindy la gare de sète de ta fille avait
avait été retirée confié au père
biologique ton et voudrait des relations
avec elle j'en suis que lé plus
intéressés par mon argent que par le
reste étant donné que la fois où j'ai
voulu la retrouver elle avait fait la
couverture de closer avec un cas de
pages avant même de me voir elle a
préféré gagner de l'argent dans une
couverture et maintenant elle dit
qu'elle veut pas elle veut pas qu'on la
reconnaisse dans la rue mais c'est elle
qui a fait une couverture avec un cas de
pages et
et je peux vous le dire à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui qu'elle n'est plus
intéressé par balles aujourd'hui voilà
qui tu peux avoir confiance personnes
encore et encore la fois tu encore envie
de te battre tu es encore je sens clac
et sur un nouveau départ here is a way
qui sont les gens qui t'entourent
aujourd'hui j'ai peu de personnes et
silvinit tels que vous connaissez donc
deux mois ce qui de toi qui te lâche pas
je sais me lâche pas j'ai eu à un ami
dia longtemps mais voilà très peu de
personnes autour de moi oui tu as peur
de l'avenir
j'ai une fois là et là exactement c'est
tout ouais ouais mais tu as peur de
l'avenir
j'ai moins peur de l'avenir j'avais peur
encore il ya quelques mois oui ce que tu
te dis que le plus dur est passé
le plus dur est passé ouais je n'ai
envie d'avancer là j'ai envie d'avancer
ouais ça se sent et vu le sang à
l'intérieur de moiry envie d'être
heureuse j'ai envie d'être heureuse mais
je crois que je le mérite
oui comment tu expliques l'ona que tous
ces gens qui étaient autour de toi t'es
pas pu leur faire confiance et que tu
dis aujourd'hui il est intéressé que par
mon argent que par marc célébrités même
des gens de ta famille c'est incroyable
voix raymond je vois tous les gens
autour de la table et 10 mai tous les
téléspectateurs doivent se dire mais
c'est un cauchemar
c'est un cauchemar ouais la famille
lezennes même sa propre maison qui on
peut pas compter sa propre fille ouais
je sais pas pourquoi tu as ta mère elle
a essayé de tout le monde quand tu étais
en hôpital psychiatrique elle et c'est
eux pourront par exemple quand tu vis
ces moments avec avec ton ex qui
t'appelle personnes qu'elle reste seul
ouais c'est pour ça qu'il a pu faire ce
qu'il a fait parce que justement quand
je lui disais à ma mère elle me disait
chacun sa merde c'est incroyable ouais
voilà qui a de quoi tu as envie
aujourd'hui d'être heureuse et ça passe
par quoi tu n'as pas soir ça passe par
se réveiller le matin se dire qu'on peut
avoir confiance en certaines personnes
ça veut dire
expliquer ce qui m'est arrivé pour
pouvoir tourner la page que refléter ce
soit oui tu es heureuse de te voir
benjamin de revoir des gens quitter oui
oui ça me fait énormément de bien de par
exemple là ça m'a changé donc fini ton
livre sexisme story oui ça c'est un
renouveau aux éditions du seuil un
signalement sérieux et ses belles
maisons rasées une très belle maison
loana pourquoi tu écris ce livre c'est
pas moi qui l'écrit n'est pas une fois
voire chaudes pjak est atteinte vous
tapez tête j'ai cautionné ce livre est
en fait c'est plus le point de vue d'un
journaliste sur le point de vue de la
télé réalité et il a fait un un portrait
sur la la la gagnante la gagnante de la
téléréalité et puis nous sommes pris
d'affection et à travers à travers moi
il est urgent qu'un peu tout ce qui peut
arriver à une gagnante de télé réalité
est ce que ça a changé dans le dans le
monde de la de la télé alors loi donc
voilà aujourd'hui j'ai dû voter tu as
vraiment beaucoup maigri
oui et je trouve ta retrouver ton ton
physique de l'oft nous et j'ai
l'impression et tu te sens mieux
oui je me sens beaucoup mieux c'est
aussi le début du renouveau
ça faisait bizarre renouveau et j'ai
l'impression voilà de me retrouver
demain on fera un gros sujet sur toutes
les stars de télé-réalité déchu qui ont
vécu un cauchemar si tu veux venir ont
parlé avec nous avec plaisir vraiment la
bienvenue
bien sûr que ça te fait du bien d'être
sur notre plateau où il y ait beaucoup à
face à nous aider aussi à penser en
cause et venir nous voir wii sera la
bienvenue match et rien avec médias vont
être remerciés pour ton témoignage
merci